[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry I'm
Francis Foster I'm Constance I'm Kissin
and this is the show for you if you're
bored of people arguing on the internet
over subjects they know nothing about
trigonometry we don't pretend to be the
experts we ask the experts
our fantastic expert guest this week is
a journalist think tank and the author
of the road to somewhere very good hi
welcome to trigonometry thank you the
question we always like to ask at the
beginning is how are you where you are
what's been your journey through life
have there been any kind of things in
your life that have informed the work
that you do and the views that you know
hold yes I'm in my entire life I guess
has helped to inform the views I have I
came from a very privileged background
my father was a Conservative MP I went
to a very grand public school
combination those two things meant you
know growing up in the you know in the
kind of seventies that inevitably I
became a leftist and at university was
really pretty pretty radical so I so I
think I kind of understand some of the
kind of mentality of the attractions
indeed of of the kind of holistic
worldview of kind of Islamism or Marxism
or whatever indeed I found being a
Marxist for a few years in my late teens
early twenties was enormous Lee
intellectually productive in some ways
because of the the kind of the kind of
intellectual vanity of Marxism you have
to be an expert will pretend to be an
expert on everything you know you have
to kind of have a theory on everything
so it's quite good training for kind of
journalism and think-tank world but I
kind of gradually read my read my way
out of the more kind of silly in extreme
views that I had at that time but I am
and I consider myself to be very much on
the center-left for I guess most of my
adult life
I after University I became a local
newspaper journalist where I'd been at
University in New York and then rather
accidentally ended up on the Financial
Times in the night early 1980s which was
wonderful training the FT then was one
of the last big institutions to believe
in the generalist principle you know you
did a subject for two or three years and
then you moved on to a completely
different subject but like the high
reaches of the civil service and I
covered the last I was a labor reporter
covering the last great disputes against
the Thatcher government in the early
eighties early mid eighties then moved
on to talking about writing about big
company takeovers and I then had the
very good fortune of going to Germany
just before unification and that was a
fantastic experience and it was that
that I I didn't you know that kind of in
a way to turn my head I didn't really
having covered a world historic event I
didn't fancy going back to the FT and
because you know spending the next 10 or
15 years becoming features editor or
whatever I might have been so I decided
to set up a magazine I set up a magazine
called prospect monthly current affairs
magazine really based on the modeled on
the American magazines like like the
Atlantic Monthly and New York via books
and New Yorker and half is I'm not
obviously we weren't going to be exactly
like them we were going to be much
smaller fry thing but mmm it was like
that they're kind of the lack of a
proper essay essay writing culture here
in our journalism that I hope to do
something about and I did that for 15
years from 95 to 2015 and intellectually
in that time I made a prospect had
started off very much it's really it was
started off in the mid 90s was seen very
much as a part of the kind of new
laborious world you know we were just
coming to that end of that long period
of conservative rule and we were not
political with a capital P but we were
kind of happy enough to be sort of go
along with that sort of reform is
site-geist but we then or I anyways
developed a kind of critique of aspects
of contemporary liberalism particularly
on issues of race and multiculturalism
and immigration and I I wrote a long
essay in 2004 it was February 2004 I
think called to diverse question mark
really aimed very much at the center
left which I still considered then my
political home essentially saying look
there is a kind of it was quite an
abstract philosophical argument saying
about the tension between the left two
favorite principles in a way the
principle of solidarity in the principle
of diversity and based on the common
sense idea that people are ready to to
share with and to trust people who
they're familiar with and they know and
they have some reciprocal experiences
with based on that common sense
assumption
you know I argued that it was an
increasingly diverse society not just
through immigration but through kind of
also you know the much greater moral
diversity value diversity of modern
societies it was it was harder to hold
on to that that sense of common identity
across across a much more varied range
of people and therefore it was much
harder to persuade people to to share
their resources and and have a degree of
trust in each other which any any decent
Society I think requires any way that
this essay was about 6,000 words but it
was printed word-for-word almost in the
Guardian I mean with our permission
obviously I was thrilled that the
Guardian wanted to reprint it but it but
it caused quite a quite a kind of little
kind of hullabaloo
anyone was willing to have it that no no
it was it was a little bit of ahead of
its time and and so I was Julie
described as a kind of nice
racist you know even nice people do
racism I think you know the could
prospect was seen as this rather sort of
genteel intellectual magazine yeah and
you know Gary young and actually even
even Trevor Phillips had a goat is
although it was it was there obviously
was a bit of a cusp moment then because
it was a better I don't think there was
any cause and effect I wouldn't claim
that but a couple of weeks later Trevor
gave an interview a famous interviewed
at the times in which he himself was
very critical of multiculturalism
thought that it is essentially kind of
overstretched and and that it was now
more important to worry about about you
know what we what we have in common
rather than always stressing the you
know the importance of separate
identities which is what multicultural
had been had been primarily doing let me
interject our international viewers
Trevor Phillips used to be the head of
the human rights and equalities
Commission and he's black as well as as
it happens
hmm anyway so that I mean I sort of
stumbled into this territory without
really having thought Barry my you know
I could have bought the package you know
I was a kind of liberal so of course I
was in favor of high levels of
immigration had them really sort of
thought about it and but that started to
sort of change my worldview to some
extent or partly the reaction to it and
and also then started to think about it
a lot of these issues a lot more and
read about them and I kept getting
invited to sort of seminars and
conferences and I was the BBC were quite
keen on me for a while because this
really was still a time when it was
quite hard to talk about there are
greater restrictions on immigration
without being considered
you know suspect on race in some way I
mean the two things I think are now much
more separated I mean issues of racial
justice which which are real
and the core economic and and cultural
issues associated with large-scale
immigration I think we now partly
because of the the immigration from
Central and Eastern Europe since 2004
five has made it easier to separate out
the two issues which is a good thing but
I do think that the the debate has
become more open and honest in some ways
since since that time but I think it's I
mean I mean becoming interested in the
subject did did cause me as it were to
sort of question some of my that kind of
liberal assumptions that I had made
earlier and and I did sort of feel
myself kind of drifting away from from
the liberal tribe as it were
and I think it was partly you know
partly realizing both my own instincts
and the instincts of many of my fellow
citizens were were much more sort of
communitarian to put it like to put it
no stronger a much less sort of
individualist Universalist which is the
sort of the sort of the default position
of so many kind of liberal minded
graduates even those on the left they
tend to they tend to be very suspicious
of sort of group attachments and group
group identities they tend to see them
as inherently kind of hostile to the
other which I don't think is either
logically or historically necessary
although clearly has sometimes been true
I mean of course the the left tends to
be hypocritical about group feelings in
that it privileges some and denigrates
others is it worm and so so the left is
still group list when it comes to social
class at least they're kind of you know
more serious left old left to be liked
but some very very suspicious of groups
when it comes to ethnicity or
or nation even and I see certain kinds
of groups as he inherently sort of
unreasonable in a way so toxic in fact
yeah but I think is that it was it was
kind of coming at the same market so I
you know as sort of populism began to
emerge as a subject I think I had a kind
of understanding you know even to some
extent a kind of sympathy with some of
the feelings that the people had about
about rapid social change and it seemed
to be completely reasonable that people
were pushing back against rapid changes
to neighborhoods and ways of life and
and and it was the that this idea this
is really something that has been it's
really an idea that Eric cowman has made
his own who I think I think you've
interviewed him already
this idea of asymmetrical
multiculturalism the fact that you know
multicultural was a it's based around
the importance of ethnicity to human
beings but only regards it somehow as
being important to ethnic minorities in
in white European societies and that
it's almost a kind of it's almost a kind
of Orientalism in relation to white
people as if white people are kind of
not really they've kind of transcended
ordinary human feelings in some magical
way and don't have ethnic feelings to
like minority people to you now of
course it's the case that majority
ethnicities are different in some ways
to minority ethnicities yes you know you
you know if it's your society you know
people like you kind of generally
speaking have more power than at least
relatively new arrivals or obviously
bound to generally have less status and
and and power in the society at least
for a generation or two so I'm not
saying that there
exactly identical but we've you know we
have clearly seen the limits of
asymmetrical multiculturalism in in
recent years when and people have pushed
back against what they see is kind of
infringement on on what they thought was
their sort of entitlement to a
relatively settled life now you know
that the modern world is is pretty
unsettling in many ways but politics
holds out at the promise I mean modern
politics modern democratic politics and
and I think we forget just how recent
really properly democratic societies
we've we've been I mean in in I mean how
relatively recently I we had a formal
democracy where we didn't have universal
franchise walk till the end of the
nineteen twenties but you had the kind
of you have the hangovers of the
attitudes of previous eras in in kind of
deference and and you know respect for
elites and and I think it's really only
in the last of 20 or 30 or 40 years you
might say that that people have come
into their full Democratic in
inheritance and you know are you know
are ready to kind of use the the
extraordinary you know equality that the
pallino political equality that
democracy offers in order to try and
resist some of the you know the perhaps
then that the necessary creative
destruction and upheavals of modern
dynamic market economies you know to try
and you know to try and so almost you
know hold the society within the bounds
of that old left slogan of years of you
also a center-left slogan a bow so yes
to a market economy but no to a market
society which I was thought was rather
an attractive way of putting it in some
ways and and and I think you know a lot
of populism you might say is part of
that to push
push back against a market society
including in its a demographic and
immigration related aspects like the
idea that everything is about the
economy so that's why we tend to have
this conversation yeah immigration yeah
strictly through the lens of the economy
right see and I'm an immigrant myself by
the way but it's just blows my mind no
one seems to ever really want to talk
about the cultural side of it the fact
that this constant churn and change also
has an impact on people's lives which
they're frankly you know this is what
Eric and Matt told us about 70% of leave
or to say they'd be prepared to lose out
financially if I meant reducing
immigration and 35 percent of them say
they'd be able to they be prepared to
lose that significantly were men
reducing immigration to zero right so
people clearly don't just measure the
success or failure of immigration based
on their car people do and yeah we
always talk about it strictly in those
terms at least yeah yeah yeah no man I
think the whole point of of the politics
that we've been seeing in the last five
or 10 years that the the new kind of
instability or all right I mean I I like
to think of it as a kind of rebalancing
we were there's been a push back against
the dominant liberalism both economic
and social and cultural liberalism of
the last 30 years now I mean I think
most of us I'm certainly not against all
of all of what liberalism has done
either economically or socially and
culturally and I think that there have
been there have been great advances in
many ways and yet we've had the great
the great liberalisation in on race on
gender on sexuality
much of which I think has been a great
human advance I mean we've taken
seriously the the the kind of the idea
of human moral equality which only
really became I mean you know like
democracy it's a remarkably recent idea
at least an idea that is properly
grounded in our in our laws and
constitutions I mean it wasn't really
until the UN Declaration of Rights in
when was it 1948 that that this idea did
become commonplace at least in Western
liberal democracies the idea of human
equality human moral
and of course again we had hangovers
from earlier era as you know older
generations found it kind of difficult
to adjust them and I think it's one of
the things that that lies behind 1968 I
mean particularly in Germany for obvious
reasons but in France too
you know the kind of the young
egalitarian minded mainly lefty students
were were saying look you know we've now
got these laws that that say that we're
all equal but you know but you know but
the older generation and not I'm not
behaving as if I said those laws were on
the statute books so and they had
something CID to beat the older
generation with they had a kind of you
know they had a righteousness let's dig
into how that happened because you
talking about this in your book and
you've come up with a way of
categorizing the different groups in
society who are engaged in this contest
which I think quite a lot of people are
now relying on as the underpinning of
their work so tell us a little bit about
the somewheres in anywheres yeah I mean
it's it's looking at value groups rather
than social classes the sort of as the
new kind of motors of politics obviously
there's some overlap but yeah but very
broadly what I'm talking about is that
is the switch from a from society from a
society in which politics is primarily
socio-economic in which social class are
the basic units in these user to do with
the kind of Marquis versus state and
size of the state and levels of public
spending and and redistribution and so
on to much more socio-cultural issues to
do with identity to do with borders
immigration nation-states and you know
security versus liberty issues in
relation to terrorism to gender equality
issues and how those are playing out so
these these kind of socio-cultural
issues have become
the kind of central currency of of
contemporary politics and that is and
that's produced new sort of groupings
and I think you know value value groups
have become as important if not more
important than social class groups and
yes in my book the road to somewhere I
talked about two in particular that took
two big ones that almost sort of you
might say are kind of analogous with
with kind of middle-class and
working-class in the older formulations
the people that see the world from
anywhere and the people see the world
from somewhere and in the anyways are
about twenty twenty five percent of the
population perhaps a little bit more in
different countries I think this applies
across most of the developed world by
the way although it plays out
differently in different places so
anyways tend to be highly educated you
know at least an undergraduate degree
sometimes postgraduate qualifications of
one kind or another so educated and
mobile generally mobile and particularly
in this country because of residential
universities where people from whatever
their social class background tend to
you know leave leave home and their
hometown and usually at the age of
eighteen and go off 100 250 miles away
to college and often never never
returned to live at least in in where
they came from and and you you
socialized with a with a with with an
entirely new group often and your could
have your cut off from the group of
people that you went to school with
often in your hometown friends this is
much less true by the way in most other
countries it is acutely I think it's one
of the reasons why some of these value
divides are particularly acute in this
country half of American students live
with their parents most most students
middle-class students that many of the
elites in continental Europe come here
to university or go to America but most
most ordinary middle-class kids in
Germany will go to the local town
university so you
more of a kind of blending you know
you're more likely to you know if you
even if you become a kind of upper
professional you're more likely to know
somebody who's a plumber or an
electrician in this country you have a
much greater apartheid as a result of of
what residential universities combined
with London - I think the London effect
tends to how much you think the class
system plays into that as well because
we are we are very structured by class
I mean Oxford is a perfect and the
co-op's bridge of a perfect example of
this we have we we can preserve more of
the external trappings of class instead
of accent and we preserved our private
schools and so on but we're actually not
that different to most other developed
countries
I'm nothing we kind of we focus on on on
the trappings as do foreigners when they
kind of observe us but a bit of but all
countries have their elite institutions
and most of those elite institutions are
full of kids from mainly elite
backgrounds you know whether the the you
know the kind of n arcs in France you
know them the more they called all those
a cold soup EF a worn all those or the
you know the Ivy League universities in
America everybody has them and it may be
that because of private schools we I
mean ours are somewhat less meritocratic
I mean you can kind of argue about that
but yes I mean there is an overlap
there's an overlap between my value
groups and social class but they are
different so you get you know you get or
you get sort of social class mixes and
indeed and indeed some ideological mixes
so you might have an any you know
typical anywhere might be a very
[Music]
internationally minded you know
management consultant speaks three or
four languages
[Music]
probably a perhaps four could be from a
middle middle class background or could
be from any banker and really immense
you know someone who's done well you
know this you know passed exams when
young went to more or less good
university has now has a successful
professional career but might have very
kind of free-market views on economics
where you know somebody who is it
equally anywhere in their in their kind
of socio-cultural worldview but is you
know an extremely left-wing sociology
professor you know but they're both
anyways because they be they share that
those basic you know they've embraced
much I mean that the left-wing sociology
professor will obviously be critical at
some aspect of of the economic
liberalism of the last 30 or 40 years
but they will both be very comfortable
in the modern world I mean they're both
I mean though the you know what
anywhere's share despite potential
disagreements over economic economic
policy is is you know they believe in
openness they believe in autonomy they
tend to be highly individualistic they
tend to be comfortable with social
change they conserve that they're
comfortable with social fluidity and
they have what the American sociologists
talk of Parsons called achieved identity
as he talked he's an incredibly boring
sociologist but he did come up with this
very useful idea of this thinking about
human identity on a spectrum between
achieved and ascribed so we all have a
mix of the two but for any people from
highly educated backgrounds to work in a
mobile and sort of individualistic in
their life paths tend to have achieved
identity it's like to say you come
people who've passed exams and gone to
good universities and have have solid
professional careers they tend to think
of themselves as the sort of consequence
of their own achievements in some ways
and obviously that's only very partly
true but it means your identity is more
so
of more can a portable you know you can
take it anywhere it's customizable as
well yeah you can fit in you know you're
you you're happy living in the kind of
edgy in a city in Tower Hamlets
surrounded by Bangladeshi people you
know British Bangladeshis or whatever
you because you have a sort of sense of
your self that's derived from your
previous life achievements these people
make up about 20-25 yeah 20 25 percent
of population yeah and there's some ways
I'm just staying on the identity things
some ways tend to have identities that
are more ascribed I think about you you
can't really change I mean you know I'm
white male British but you know you
could I don't you could be a Scottish
farmer or a working-class Geordie or
obviously you can change your class but
but you know your if your identity is
mainly ascribed to you then you your
identities derived from your the place
that you come from and the groups that
you belong to some of which obviously
you can't change someone you can and
therefore I think it's much you know if
you so some ways you know just doing my
general schpeel in some way some ways
unlike any ways tend to be much more
rooted tend to be much less
well-educated tend to value the things
that you would expect people with more
from more rooted backgrounds to value
security familiarity and so on but also
just leaping back to the identity idea
they're they're having a mainly ascribed
identity means that your identity is
very much tied in with the places and
groups that you come from so if those
places and groups change your identity
is much more susceptible to being
discomforted by social change so I think
the two really important differences
between the anywhere and the somewhere
world for you and the anywhere and
somewhere people is that you know like
anywhere is a comfortable with social
change and some ways they obviously some
some ways can be but I mean obviously
I'm generalizing I'm talking in averages
most somewheres are more likely to see
changes loss partly cuz they're through
being less well educated they're less
well-equipped to
- to achieve well in the in the modern
world so they're more likely to see but
the odd the other big thing so it's
attitude to social change and attitude
to group attachment anyways like like we
were talking about earlier
anywhere's tend to be rather suspicious
of group attachment even rather look
down upon it whereas to some ways it's
it's an it's an important sort of
emotional sustenance to their lives
often not always so I think that those
are the two big differences and it's and
I've invented those labels in and that
they'd rather caught on and it's and why
the book did quite well I think
is that they seem to they seem to be
quite useful ways of looking at the
modern world thinking through that
thinking of the world being divided
between anywheres in some ways but it
does you know a lot of the critics of
the book sort of said you know how how
sort of simplistic and binary and
actually if you read the book you'll
find it's not that binary I mean that
these are big baggy groupings as I said
they're a bit like kind of working-class
and middle-class we don't know one goes
around sort of saying oh that's far too
binary we kind of understand that they
don't necessarily say a huge amount
about you but they kind of give it a
general fix on on somebody and and they
kind of you know they sort of work in a
rough-and-ready way obviously India
there are all sorts of different kinds
of anyways you know I mean I have all
sorts of subsets there are all sorts of
different kinds of somewhere so you know
they could high end any anyways there
was a group about three five percent of
the population who one who were real
convert global villages I mean the kind
of citizens of nowhere that Teresa may
talked about and then it bottom end of
some ways you might again on the sort of
value spectrum see people who are
genuine authoritarians and xenophobes
perhaps three five percent of the
population perhaps a bit more on some
issues and there's also big in between a
group we
a group who share almost equally the
kind of the valley worldview of the any
worse than the value worldview some ways
now like I said I invented the labels
but I didn't I mean that these these
value groups really are there in the
data is the academics like to say
otherwise the labels would be yes yeah
yeah well but I mean well a lot of
people have questioned them but I mean
if you look at the British social
attitudes service I mean that it's not
written down there you know anyways you
know yeah but but if you can interrogate
the you know British social attitudes
have been asking people about a whole
range of things including in this whole
social socio-cultural area for thirty
five forty years until you know you can
see the evolution of these values and
ideas and the anywhere group is growing
very rapidly I mean that this is you
know one of the one of the reasons for
the political instability and
uncertainty more recent times is that
it's kind of an that the growth partly
through the expansion of our education
and our higher education particularly
humanities and social scientists are
kind of engines for creating anyways in
some ways and they have you know you
have to go back only about thirty or
forty years and perhaps the anyway the
people who would have self-consciously
ascribed to a kind of any work worldview
would have been five ten percent of the
population it's now three four times
that and and and another reason for the
for the and that's come on balance thing
it's on balance society in some ways
well this is what I was gonna let's get
right into doing because this is all
absolutely fascinating and I views will
be enjoying this but if we make this
theoretical conversation a little bit
more practical yeah and we look at
what's been happening in Western mmm
developed society over the last two or
three years particularly I mean it's
obviously part of a much longer process
but if we look what's happening now is
it essentially a question of the fact
that anywheres have been the ruling
caste [ __ ] yeah good period of time yeah
and some ways they're rebelling yeah
that's essentially it's it's a
rebalancing to push back against
anywhere over domination and I think
anyway as you know and well we can come
on to solutions later but
I think anyways have often been
oblivious of their power they haven't
realized that they are you know only a
quarter or most a third of the society
and they have assumed I mean you know
often with the best of motives they've
assumed that they have been acting in
the in the general interest when they've
actually been helping to shape a society
that is overwhelmingly intra in the
interests of people like them who have
had their kind of backgrounds who are
highly educated you know we you know one
can go through the list of you know the
knowledge economy you know I mean
they're very phrase suggests this is an
economy that works best for people who
are highly educated you've had rapid
deindustrialization in other areas
you've you've had meaning it's it's it's
become harder for large section throb
but what you've had to something I
didn't emphasize in the road to
somewhere but I but there's actually
something I'm working on now for another
book the way in which cognitive ability
has become the kind of gold standard of
human esteem he's also a very recent
thing they were there was a place for
people who were not highly abled
cognitively cognitive abilities just one
quite narrow form of human attitude and
the way both in economics and indeed in
in in education policy I mean the
massive expansion of higher education in
this country at least the continuing
neglect of technical and vocational
education you know is another area of
kind of unconscious anywhere domination
but but i think i think underpinning all
of it is the way in which we've searched
we've got a tilted the balance away from
other forms of human aptitude and people
who who felt that they had that they had
meaningful lives what i'm increasingly
realizing is that actually you know look
at looking and we'll come on to the
prison in a minute but I mean looking
macro historical if you think of we
think of industrial the transition from
an agrarian to an industrial
as a as a kind of ghastly violent visit
physically violent processes people
poured into the kind of teeming
industrial cities and and for a short
period of time it was pretty dreadful
although pretty well from the beginning
actually longevity and and an income and
then pretty well everything rose pretty
rapidly
but what we sort of forget about the
transition is actually how much
continuity there was it did not the the
process of industrialization in the
nineteenth century did not undermine
traditional religious beliefs
indeed it created new forms of
Christianity Methodism wesley ism in the
big big in the big industrial cities did
not undermine the family rates of
illegitimate she fell pretty radically
and through the nineteenth century not I
mean life was compared to today
obviously life is pretty hard in school
but you know bring bring it forward to
the 20th century and combine it with
democracy in welfare states and bear in
mind also that industrials desire to
produce new forms of of meaning and
identity through particularly for men
through skilled and semi-skilled
industrial employment you compare that
to the shift from an industrial to a
post-industrial society which is kind of
what were what we're living through now
and I think you see how lots of
traditional sources of meaning have been
destroyed I mean are you know anywhere
cultural the the kind of cultural
hegemony of the anywhere classes has
tended to be very secular Stena to be
very liberal has tended to and has
tended as I said to focus very much on
one form of human aptitude that our
cognitive ability and if you don't you
know if you don't get through the
bottleneck you know if you're not an
exam pass when you're young and you
don't get into the the kind of higher
into the a-level stream and then into a
good university these days not even any
university or Bay
it has to be a good university we've
narrowed the kind of source of human
esteem and meaning to that outcome and
if you think of all that all the kind of
institutions that give you meaning and
recognition unconditionally
you know like religion itself is fading
away the family has obviously been under
great pressure in in recent generations
and they're not you know other you know
like institutions that you know like the
the big industrial factory the the
military you know the institutions that
provided roles and meaning and
usefulness to millions and millions of
people who didn't necessarily thrive
academically or cognitively and so I
think I think this is a kind of this is
sort of underlying explanation I think
for a lot of the it's that it's the kind
of arrogance of the cognitive elites who
have decided that that they're that
they're sort of their form of aptitude
is is the one that should should hold
sway and and without I mean they haven't
they haven't intentionally downgraded
other forms of aptitude but I think you
know whether it's sort of technical
manual functions or caring the caring
economy you know we pay lip service to
the to the to the wonderful nurses or
social care workers but we pay them
absolutely dreadfully and and we know we
continue to we continue to that the
other thing about the kind of anywhere
worldview it's very very public realm
focused you know it's about work and
politics and public life but actually
for most people the most important
things in life are in the private realm
it's you know it's your kind of private
life and your family life and things
like that and we matter and I think we
hugely under the sort of underestimate
the important that's one of the reasons
why so many the caring jobs the jobs it
used to be done
in the emotional economy of the family
by women overwhelmingly for for free you
know in our grandmother's generation
many of those jobs are now done outside
the home but partly for that reason
partly because there used to be done for
free inside the family they're somehow
they're they're held in in relatively
low esteem but I think that's a more a
more general function of holding the
product that anyways tend to hold the
private realm and you see this in modern
feminism which is a very very intense to
be very dominated by kind of upper
professional anywhere women you know
they can Hakeem organs and hairy arms
tend to have a tend to not have a very
keen interest in the private realm I
mean they they see that it's kind of
belonging to woman's past in some ways
and the important thing now is you know
is is being able to compete equally with
men in the in the public realm but I
mean I think you know if you kind of
look at opinion data and things like
that that doesn't seem to be a view that
is that is shared by most women in
Britain I'm an officer most women
Britain want to be able to compete
equally with men in public realm but
they want to place much greater
influence than much in modern feminism
does on on the private realm of the
family and being able to stay at home
when your children are very young for
two or three years many many women and
indeed some men would like to do that
but it's almost it's become almost
impossible for most for most families to
be able to afford to do that and we have
no support for in the tax system very
very minimal support in the tax system
for for families has been wanting to
jump in about 20 minutes he's far too
British to Europe that's the thing yeah
I'll be the far in hand go
I think you've touched on something
because I was a teacher for 10 years
right and I taught in primary are
talking secretary and I talked with
deprived communities and I think you've
really touched on something there about
the anyways and I'm pretty much a man
anywhere but I think it's the arrogance
anywhere and I think it's their idea
that they know best and we saw that with
brexit where it'll be anyways well what
a surprise everyone voted for braixen
it's like no you weren't listening and
I've seen it more and more and more how
in education unless you absque ride to
these sets of values unless you are you
know good at essentially taking
information regurgitating it you were
thrown on the scrap heap metaphorically
and uh one question I want to ask you is
at the moment it feels were polarized
how do we bridge that gap it can we do
it or is this sense because of
Technology and because of the way the
exact Asian system is they're
essentially the gap is gonna grow wider
and wider I think we can bridge the gap
I mean I mean with some difficulty I
mean it's the the purpose of politics is
to bridge the gap in a way I mean that
is what most you know that is what good
politicians should be focusing upon I
mean it's what you know politics is is
in a sense always a base about trying to
try to bring conflicting views and and
indeed conflicting interests together in
to some degree or finding compromises
that allows allows different groups to
to function relatively happily together
in the same Society I mean I think
obviously obviously the brexit and
create these divisions these divisions
that have emerged particular
particularly strongly over the last 20
or 30 years in response to they are both
both the cultural arrogance but also the
over domination that we talked about
earlier and and and and one
manifestation of that over domination
whether it's in the field of the economy
whether it's in the field of
of Education the massive over expansion
of our education whether it's in you
know whether it's in in the in the kind
of almost the dealer chittim ization of
many small c conservative views and
tradition you know kind of you know male
breadwinner i mean i mean lots of men
you know for the last couple of
centuries have got out of bed in the
morning essentially because they feel
the responsibility of being a
breadwinner now for perfectly good
reasons in some cases that has that has
gone or had become less important
because women have become much more
autonomous which is a good thing on the
whole i mean my my mother just kind of
missed out on on kind of mainstream
modern feminism and and and and suffered
for that in many ways and you know
wasn't able to live the same sort of
wasn't able to be as fulfilled as as her
has her daughters and granddaughters but
um you know in in all these different
areas i mean quite large minorities if
not majorities of our society have have
not have not felt you know this whole
kind of you know left v right has been
replaced by open v closed is incredibly
self-serving way of looking in the world
i mean i've never met anyone who wants
to live in a closed gulag like society
nobody does obviously but a lot of
people feel that the forms are modern
openness that we've created in the last
thirty years you know i mean I mean
symbolized most graphically by you know
the supply chain going to China the
rapid industrial deindustrialization of
Britain America even more so perhaps
[Music]
parts of Britain and and symbolized also
by large-scale immigration and that
thing that they're kind of double whammy
the feeling that you know your factory
closes and goes to probably not China
out of Vietnam or Cambodia or somewhere
but then a whole new work
force is introduced into the country to
compete with you in the service jobs
that you're probably then doing came as
a real shock to people I think and most
of those people it's so important to
emphasize this against the contempt of
much modern liberalism most of those
people are not hostile to the individual
immigrant they're anti-immigration
they're not anti-immigrant I mean it's a
it's an elysian that liberals often make
you know such and such you know the
anti-immigrant party the anti-immigrant
politician there are some but most of
the time people are hostile to the
immigration and not the immigrant you
know people who work in fish finger
factories in Hull probably go out to to
drink after work with the with the pole
or Slovenian they're working beside
they're not hostile to the individual
that doesn't mean to say they think it's
in their economical cultural interests
to have had that movement of people on
such a large scale clearly it is very
much part of the kind of you know the
liberal market system and it's it's one
part of it that has not on the whole
benefited people and so people have
rightly pushed back against it so how
can we resolve this because what France
because well time is almost what are
some of the potential ways of well I
mean I think a lot of the emphasis is on
a lot of the responsibility for this we
know we've had anywhere liberal
overreach in many in many aspects of our
societies and we need and and and
anyways need to be more emotionally
intelligent about the extent of their
domination they need to and you're
seeing this already or sort of seeing
the kind of anywhere classes I think
dividing between the kind of admonished
anyways you know the kind of Teresa Mays
who are sort of saying you know it's
true we didn't really listen to people
and we bloody well should have done you
know otherwise we wouldn't have ended up
with brexit you know that this is our
fault in many years and then you got the
kind of militant anyways you know the AC
Grayling's and all of the cams who are
sort of saying you know we're
they are the barbarians you know where
the we're the decent to civilize people
I think you are seeing that division I
mean I think and I think and hope
obviously the kind of admonished
liberals anyways will will win their
argument and and and what you know there
is still a quite a lot of common ground
and when one shouldn't I mean there's a
lot of polarization is obviously
magnified by social media and so on you
know you you know obviously social media
gives a megaphone to relatively small
groups that we sometimes have the
impression I think they were more
polarized than we are
we're I'm not denying that we are
polarized we do have these value divides
mm-hmm and we need to find ways of
finding common ground again or finding
some sort of settlement you know though
post brexit and I think they're kind of
contours of it a reasonably clear and it
has to do with having having greater
respect for the more settled part of our
population after all this has been I
mean you know the you know these people
are not militants this is a very diffuse
emissive defensive it's a defensive
impulse it is not you know this is not
the 1930s they're not sort of we're not
thinking about kind of invading Denmark
you know it's about holding on to
something that people wanted you know
which was a relatively stable life and
and and I think politics will have to
take that into account more and it
already is it's already doing so and
with difficulty is true but I mean it
breaks it was essentially a somewhere
policy that is now being implemented
rather reluctantly by anyways both in
the civil service and indeed in that you
know the 70% of political class was was
was was remainer but that sort of taps
into the fear from the from the some
ways that they're all right they they
made their point they said this is what
they want they want they want and now
the fear is that the anyways are not
going to implement it or if they do
they're not going to implement it
properly and they're gonna fudge it and
my favorite and constant is fear is that
if that happens that then allows the
lens how big the fudge is I think I mean
I mean I think
a few days ago
and I said but we are very much both of
us now coming right into the position of
those
anywhere's who have woken up yeah yeah
same here hold on a second
if brexit isn't delivered embrace' is
seriously fighting this is what I said
I'll be C or if we have a second vote
you could poison our politics
regeneration I agree welcome well I
actually said on the program I thought
that if brexit it doesn't get delivered
you could have a political movement in
this country led by someone like Tommy
Robinson with funding from someone like
Steve Bannon and you already see it
happening Steve Burns already talking
about Tommy Robinson being a British
patriot and all this stuff is happening
and I got a lot of crap from both sides
for saying that you kid will have 50 MPs
even with first-past-the-post I think I
mean really if we if we really have a
brexit in name only however having said
that I mean I think there is also a
strong case for having a degree of fudge
because it was only 52 48 it was 52 48
and so and I think you know you can't
you know we don't want a
winner-takes-all brexit either we don't
want to kind of a really hard brexit but
i mean there is a there is a kind of
reasonable there is respecting brexit
sufficiently without you know while
taking into account the views of the 48
- and i mean that that's a very kind of
difficult combination um I know that
that is partly why our own internal
argument has been so difficult let alone
negotiation with with Brussels and
people sort of say oh how awful it is
but actually this is what this is
democracy that's it's it's it's a mess
but it's a democratic mess it's an
unavoidable democratic mess given the
52:48 outcome and i think and i think it
hope that we will get some kind of deal
it'll be sufficient it won't be it won't
be perfect there'll be grumbles on on
both sides but yeah we really do then
have to get down to two
these these internal differences of
which brexit was a kind of manifestation
and I think you know and brexit in a
sense will be the first step towards
that sorting out it does give us it does
allow us to repatriate some of our
democratic accountability and it allows
us to you know to have a radical
industrial policy if we want to know
there may be many arguments against
having that but we can do stuff now or
after brexit will be able to do stuff
that we couldn't before and and I hope a
lot of that energy goes into I mean you
know the anywhere dominated political
class is had a huge shock from brexit
and I think you know and we aren't doing
you know we have a apprenticeship levy
okay people criticize the way it's been
implemented you know we have tea levels
I mean there is a recognition that we've
got over over expand in higher education
you know the ridiculous idea that 50% of
of kids go to it's not so much obviously
we need we need forms of post school
education when all developed countries
have but we've gone for a very very
narrow classical university structure
three or four years often often through
boarding as I was saying residential you
know and even if you're you know even if
you're doing a degree in construction
management you still and half the time
writing essays I mean so they are very
very academic and like other countries
have a much greater range of post school
institutions you know catering for a
much greater range or a different range
of functions and aptitudes and abilities
so you know the community colleges in
America or the fat horseshoe or in in
Germany and things like that you know we
we can we know I think we'll kind of
probably move in that direction more
thinking you know worrying less about
that pushing more and more kids to
university I think levels of immigration
will come down they're already coming
down partly because of the the falling
Sterling's made it less attractive
economically for the for the kind of
commuter immigrant to come here and and
you know just what what we really need
above all I think is and what I
we'll come from this is actually
liberals becoming less a liberal you
know liberals actually becoming more
pluralistic accepting that there are
other forms of life apart from their own
sort of you know Russell Group
universities liberalism and their sort
of you know androgynous feminism
whatever that you know that other people
live by different lights and they're not
monsters that they they they have small
see conservative views about a lot of
things but then they're decent people
still they're decent populist so I used
the phrase decent populist in my book
and what I mean by that is basically
people who've accepted the great
liberalisation they accept the idea of
human equality they don't they obviously
don't think they have the same
obligation to all humans in the world
you know they they they're they believe
in you know in their in their group
their country and the interests of you
know National Citizen rights before
universal rights then it's so they're
not liberals but they but they're but
they're they're part of them you know
modern in a very broad sense kind of
liberal acceptance of human equality but
they think that that the society has not
reflected their interests and and
they're often quite traditional small
see conservative interests and I think
the the interesting thing is that with
that politics you know the American
political scientist Daniel Bell who
talked about he talked about some time
back in the 1980s talk about his
political credo and he said he was a I'm
editing slightly but he said he was a
kind of market friendly social democrat
in economics he was broadly liberal in
politics and he was somewhat
conservative in social and cultural
matters and that combination seems to me
the kind of hidden majority you know
societies in some ways and it's for all
sorts of historical reasons the party
political system is not not reflected
that that combination although perhaps
you might say the Tory manifesto the
last election probably came closer to it
and anything in recent politics but it's
sort of how how we can kind of represent
that hidden hidden majority in our
political system I think he's one of one
of the things that
will it will kind of emerge over the
next over the next few years in the post
brexit world Francis you've barely got a
word in edgeways listen to you so why
don't you do the last question okay okay
so we are running out of time so David
what we like to finish up with is is
there one issue that people aren't
talking about that should be talking
about that we should all be talking
about something maybe that we gloss over
and why yeah I mean III do think the you
know trays may talked about her burning
in justices and I think in many cases
she's she she focused on very much the
kind of Whitehall sort of liberal
establishment burning in justices I mean
the you know gender pay gap yeah but the
gender pay gap is overwhelmingly the
result of of the Preferences expressed
the different preference is expressed by
men and women the fact that women when
they have young children overwhelmingly
choose to work part-time etc etc I think
there I mean it's there are series in
justices in some of the ways that I mean
one of the biggest injustice is not and
it's very hard to know quite what to do
about it although in it in a clumsy way
the Tory manifesto I just referred to it
sort of had a kind of failed bash at it
the extraordin this is actually an
economic thing in a way rather than
we've been talking many about cultural
things but the fact the you know the
enormous unearned increase in wealth
arbitrary honor and increase in wealth
for people who happen to live you know
in London parts of the southeast and
little pockets of the rest of the
country as a result of the increasing
value of their houses he's going to
create down the road a real problem
unless we find some fair way of kind of
tapping into it I mean we've got you
know ten million people in this country
are now
yeah you know wealthy I'm an upset small
slice of them that they're kind of
traditionally wealthy but ten million
people who happen to own properties in
the right part of the country you know
unaccountably an unexpectedly rich and
you know so I mean the whole issue of an
of inheritance is going to become really
thorny one I think because it's a
natural human impulse you want to kind
of hand on what you have to your
children and you know how we how we tap
into that that wealth you know without I
mean if I allowed a second one I mean I
would say that it which almost sort of
conflicts with that first one is the way
in which modern family policy I think
influenced very much by a kind of
anywhere professional feminism has
really not placed enough effort on
supporting young couples bringing up
young children in much of continental
Europe you essentially you know if
you're a young couple bringing up
children you essentially pay no tax or
very little tax whereas here we do not
allow couples and I don't think issue
I don't you what he should have to be
married I think the genies out of the
bottle on that I think you know anyone
who can prove they've been cohabiting
for a couple years and they have a kid
together should be able to share their
tax allowances I mean that would make a
huge difference you know we have what
are you know it's twelve twelve and a
half thousand pounds you know you can
combine two people's tax allowances and
you're already pretty much in the
average wage and we spend nine billion
pounds on child care subsidizing child
care you can't get a penny of that to
look after your own child you know we do
this anywhere public realm focus and and
much of contemporary feminism has
adopted that similarly sort of public
realm focus as a as a measure of of
equality but there are millions of
families who would
you know who and most most of us most
human beings in Britain it's you know
most of the things that really matters
are in the private realm and and we're
not doing nearly and we have a we have a
huge amount of family breakdown we're
not quite as bad as America but were
worse than much of continental Europe
you know only less than half of
fifteen-year-olds I think still live
with their their two biological parents
this is not a good state of affairs and
we've been and we've been too blase
about it and and I think you know it's a
combination of a certain sort of liberal
individualist sort of squeamishness
combined with certain a certain strand
of modern feminism has has prevented us
providing more support for young
families when they really need it I mean
it's not only you know people break up
for all sorts of reasons it's not just
money but money will often be behind
conflict in a family and we need to we
need to do much more to help people stay
together and bring up kids in in a
secure environment I think this
interview for the fewest questions
you're very active on Twitter I notice
in battles pretty much every day with
different people so if anyone wants to
follow you on twitter and be a kind of
peaceful observer to these battles are
you on Twitter at I am oh gosh when I'm
David under school Goodhart is that well
double check not that yeah I'm
definitely David is there something else
no no that sounds like a I'm hat Dave
yeah yeah yeah really also is the book
that you so fascinatingly talked about
it's called the road to somewhere yeah
the road to somewhere yeah I will put a
link to that as well the policy exchange
I work at politics change think-tank and
I'm doing another book in the next year
or so basically on this theme of you
know how smart people are to politically
powerful well
come back and talk to us about them yeah
when I was ready to go yeah oh yeah
absolutely and just to say thank you
very much guys if you've watched it we
hope you enjoy the show if you could
click Subscribe if you hit the bell
button which is on the right of the
screen that will keep you updated when
we get all the videos if you were
listening to this on iTunes um please
click Subscribe leave us a review say
something nice and if you enjoy it and
you really like it I'm telling friend
tell a friend about it and like I said
before if you don't like someone
recommend it and yeah and if you're not
enjoying it recommend it to someone you
don't like but it's been great thanks
very much and we'll see you all this yep
see you next week